welcome to this video playing wide
against Hester best horses our best yep
and he's got a picture of it yep that's
cool ok I have played them quite often
but not recently for four out of seven
is the squad okay using this this line
yeah yeah yeah people people really play
that that strange-looking move but it
did it it recently has some become very
popular on the top level this this
Bishop is Bishop is six more attacking
see form an idea three is one possible
replying unfortunately it's something
that I have not studied really but okay
efore h6 i think this is transposing
into a known variation Oh is just going
back okay
hmm it's giving me many more soon
let's think about this for just one
moment ma'am okay probably castling is
ok just thinking if I can somehow we use
this kind of we had set up at least it
it's very weird form for my chest taste
to this kind of did that thing that he
has yes there okay um g6 what about t6
isn't this good night h5 takes their
nine ith five is ok amazing okay then
I'm taking not a not a problem so what
if I now cannot take
cannot take on f7 I mean okay I'm
projecting your form and keep it simple
just stating that his Bishop is not
great on c6 and the night on b6 also
it's not ideal my night on h3 yes I know
but it's relatively quick quickly back
into the game so night f2 for possible
night d3si five on 93-5 the bishop is
going there okay
not to be false also interesting to e5
yeah then it probably just goes back
okay let's put it back down looks like
the right square for this piece
therefore if I've no probably not night
over to deform that sets it's it's more
an idea maybe
so he wants to be Bishop a form you know
but nothing I can do about that just
prove a little bit
want to control the fomc form oh I
didn't even see that this is possible
ok
check yeah my king is playing which is
nice so 68 maybe or c8c eight and then
96 maybe
let's see moopty for 1908 that sets a
bit lame look d3 for Roxy three SS this
is a bit more interesting ok now let's
try let's try that but he has luke t 7
which is probably okay that is okay
Lucas III can go up to 7 which saves the
save the whole thing family time morning
we'll have to be quick
Jeff yeah so he equalled with precise
play but I'm a bit below on time I can
track that all laughing might play on
time of course game gran ok didn't tell
I probably had some chances somewhere
because I just had the farm or more
active position down but maybe I plated
them be too too conservatively let's say
always had something but not not enough
yeah maybe here maybe teaching is better
this is what the engine gifts and then
this move that's strong that's it wrong
probably it is just not enough yeah the
child is always am I better king and so
on but it's um it's probably just not
going to going to be anything I 93 is
strong oh yeah that's true that's true
this 5f for idea is something that I
noticed later but not with the night
there s 95 is always hitting him channel
idea that's just the draw are nice of
him to to actually take it and not try
to win this on time hmm chum okay did I
have something in the immediate opening
phase because to be honest it looks
really a bit crazy putting this back
there Michael compass and giving
anything this first I thought this move
at night age five is a bit bit it was
actually interesting this is a move i
did not see
and why it is quite quite fine no but I
think that maybe yeah this is true queen
e 2 is good Queenie two is good hmm
that's a miscer that I I want to keep
the Queen's onium that was better I'm
not sure how much this code while is
definitely better with this active
pieces some somewhat better that was
strong layer I shouldn't have allowed
the Queen trade okay well thanks for
watching